ايه عقيد حاتم مرحبا بك معنا ابدا من حيث
يعني من المعلومه التي تحدث بها مراسلنا
لياس كرام نقله عن خبراء عسكريين بان هذه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تجري
قد يعني هي تراوح مكانها هل تتفق مع مثل
هذا التوجه وهذه القراءه من قبل الخبراء
العسكريين
الاسرائيليين نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره لا شك عندما نقرن هذه العمليه
العسكريه بالاهداف التي انطلقت من اجلها
نجد بان الاهداف العسكريه لم تحقق لحد هذه
اللحظه وبالتالي عندما نتساءل ما هو جدول
العمليه العسكريه من لحد هذه اللحظه من
هذا التدمير وهذا الدخول وهذه الخسائر نجد
بان الاهداف الحقيقيه لم يحقق اي منها وقد
اضافوا هدف جديد الان وهو اقامه المنطقه
العازله يعني بمعنى نحن امام اربعه اهداف
لم يحقق منها اي شيء وبالتالي الجميع
يتساءل يعني ما هو جدوى هذه العمليه
العسكريه في في الداخل في داخل المطقه
قطاع غزه بشكل عام يعني سواء في الشمال او
في الوسط او في الجنوب ولكن بشكل عام يوجد
توغل نعم هذا التوغل موجود في جميع
المناطق الان هناك توغل ولكن القضيه
المهمه بانه هناك عمليه استخدام للارض من
بعدين البعد الاول هو فوق الارض تستخدمها
فصائل المقاومه للمواجهه ولتنفيذ عمليات
على الارض وهي واضحه للعيان وهناك ايضا
قضيه الانفاق التي تعتبر هي التحدي الاكبر
في هذه العمليه العسكريه والتي يتم
توظيفها من قبل فصائل المقاومه للظهور خلف
خطوط العدو وفي مناطق قريبه لتنفيذ عمليات
ثم الانسحاب مره اخرى يضاف الى ذلك بانه
تم توظيف هذه الانفاق ل من خلال التفخيخ
ومصائد المغفلين بتفجير اكبر عدد من هذه
الانفاق بوجه القطعات التي حاولت التقدم
من خلالها e